لقد رأيت مقابلتك
قبل بضعة أيام فقط مع السفيرة الإسرائيلية، لقد
قالت هنا على هذا المقعد على هذا المقعد أنهم
وفروا جنوب
غزة بأكمله كمنطقة آمنة وأنهم
يبنون ملاجئ
للمدنيين الفلسطينيين، لقد أخبرتك بذلك وقلت
هل تحديتها، قلت رغم ذلك، هل تحديتها، لقد
بدأت تلك
المحادثة معها بإظهار
المشاعر المتدفقة الجيدة بالنسبة لك بشأن
الأمهات، لماذا لم تبدأ معي
بالآلاف من
جدات الأمهات، حرفيًا
معي جيدًا يا سعادة السفير هذا  هل هو
عدم التماثل، هذا هو الحال عندما
يجلس مسؤول إسرائيلي هنا ويخبر العالم
أن قطاع غزة جنوب قطاع غزة آمن
ويجب على الناس الذهاب إلى هناك بشكل جماعي،
وبالتالي التطهير العرقي لهؤلاء
الأشخاص في الجنوب
لذبحهم فعليًا ثم تقومون
بيرس لا تنظر في عينيها
وتطلب منها التوقف عن
الكذب